voy a hacerte lo que creo es una
pregunta interesante alguna vez te has
sentado en una habitación a temperatura
ambiente digamos que alrededor de 21
grados celsius y visto un vaso con agua
líquida espontáneamente tener hielo en
el centro
supongo que nunca lo has visto y dirías
por supuesto que no vería hielo
formándose espontáneamente especialmente
si la habitación está a 21 grados
celsius que es una temperatura superior
al punto de congelación del agua pero mi
pregunta es por qué no porque eso no
parece desafiar cualquiera de las leyes
de la física la física newtoniana o
incluso la primera ley de la
termodinámica entonces vamos a pensar en
como eso podría ocurrir vamos a imaginar
un montón de moléculas de agua en estado
líquido tengo un montón de moléculas de
agua en estado líquido y tiene una
temperatura promedio recuerda la
temperatura es solo la energía cinética
promedio por lo que cada una de estas va
a tener su propia velocidad y su propio
momento todos van a estar rebotando de
maneras diferentes y tienen enlaces o
puentes de hidrógeno entre ellas es por
eso que el agua se encuentra en estado
líquido a temperatura ambiente a
diferencia de su estado gaseoso
algunos enlaces de hidrógeno entre ellas
pero no voy a entrar en mucho detalle al
respecto por el momento te puedes
imaginar que están rebotando en formas
aleatorias pero que hay cierta
probabilidad de que interactúen de la
forma correcta de manera que tal vez
esta molécula por aquí golpee a esta
molécula de la manera correcta y
transfiera la mayor parte de su momento
a esta molécula y así ésta pierde algo
de su momento y se ralentiza mientras
esto ocurre aquí al lado una de las
otras moléculas transfiere la mayor
parte de su momento a alguna otra
molécula y también se ralentiza así que
todas ellas tienen un momento mucho
menor y tal vez está al mismo tiempo
también choca con otra molécula por lo
que se ralentiza y luego las otras a las
que les fue transferido el momento ahora
todas ellas se están moviendo más rápido
así que digamos que a esta le
transfirieron momento
a esta le transfirieron momento y a esto
también le transfirieron momento a esta
le transfirieron momento y a ésta le
transfirieron momento y ahora estas
moléculas por aquí su momento es lo
suficientemente pequeño sus velocidades
son lo suficientemente pequeñas que los
postes de hidrógeno actúan y empiezan a
formar una estructura cristalina se
están enfriando tanto que se congelan se
están convirtiendo en hielo y porque
esto no puede suceder en lo que acaba de
describir sólo estoy hablando de
moléculas que chocan entre sí y
transfieren su momento estoy hablando de
energía que no se crea ni se destruye
por lo que parece ir de acuerdo con la
primera ley de la termodinámica así que
parece ser que en teoría podría ser
posible que el hielo se forme
espontáneamente o tal vez otra manera de
pensar en ello tal vez es posible
empezar con un sistema que es uniforme
a una temperatura promedio pero tal vez
se podría formar un poco de hielo aquí
si el resto del agua que se encuentra
alrededor se calienta tal vez al inicio
toda el agua está a 21 grados celsius
todo esto está a una temperatura neutral
de 21 grados celsius pero tal vez hay
cierta probabilidad de que de forma
espontánea sin tener creación o pérdida
de energía parte de la energía de la
zona central se transfiera hacia el
exterior por lo que el exterior se
calienta así que tal vez toda esta parte
externa del agua se calienta
esta es una vista aérea del vaso con
agua tal vez toda esta zona del agua se
calienta y toda el agua en el centro se
enfría pero tienen la misma energía
cinética total así que no se ha creado
ni perdido energía simplemente ocurrió
que de manera espontánea hubo
transferencia de energía desde la zona
central hacia el exterior e incluso
conforme la zona del centro se enfría
cada
más se transfiere más y más energía del
agua fría hacia el agua caliente y se
queda de esta manera este escenario se
siente que podría ser posible debido a
algo de la física que ya conocemos
pero algunas personas reflexivas como
estos señores de aquí este es carnage
considerado como el padre de la
termodinámica kelvin y rudolf clausus
ellos observaron repetidamente y se
dieron cuenta de que esto no parece
ocurrir en la naturaleza especialmente
cuando se llega a los estudios de kelvin
y clausus ellos dicen no se ve que
ocurra transferencia de calor de frío a
caliente y puesto que no estamos
observando que ocurra vamos a añadir
nuestra segunda ley de la termodinámica
la da
cunda
la segunda ley
d
hola
termo
una mica
la segunda ley de la termodinámica es
empírica se basa en la observación y la
segunda ley de la termodinámica de
acuerdo con rudolf clausus y voy a
parafrasear esto es que no vemos una
transferencia espontánea de calor desde
las zonas frías hacia las zonas
calientes
déjame escribir eso
hay transferencia
espontánea
d
y calor
de frío
ah
caliente no hay transferencia espontánea
de calor de frío a caliente y voy a
subrayar la palabra caliente
y esto estuvo basado en la observación
porque no vemos que esto ocurra de
manera espontánea no vemos que el agua
se organice de pronto y tenga una región
caliente y una región fría y enfriarse
tanto que se congele de forma espontánea
lo que si observamos es que si colocará
un vaso con agua y hielo en una
habitación a temperatura ambiente voy a
ver que ocurre lo contrario voy a ver
que hay transferencia de calor de las
zonas cálidas a las zonas frías
esta es el agua
vamos a ver que hay transferencia de
calor en el otro sentido de las regiones
calientes a las regiones frías ahora
bien esta fue una observación empírica y
estaba soportada por la experimentación
pero porque vemos que esto sucede y
resulta que hay una muy muy muy muy muy
pequeña probabilidad de que esto suceda
recuerda que en los sistemas reales y la
termodinámica es el estudio de los
sistemas más que de las moléculas
individuales en cualquier sistema del
que estemos hablando hay muchas muchas
más moléculas que sólo estas tres
moléculas de aquí
si nos fijamos en el número de moléculas
que hay en un vaso con agua estamos
hablando de cifras con 24 ó 25 ceros
dependiendo del tamaño del vaso con agua
que tengas así que estamos hablando de
un gran gran número de moléculas y
estadísticamente y ellos no pensaron en
esto de manera estadística hasta que
boltzmann lo hizo pero estadísticamente
las probabilidades de que esto ocurra
son tan bajas especialmente cuando
pensamos en más de tres moléculas y
estoy hablando de mucho mucho más de
tres moléculas y podemos pensar en esto
si fuéramos a verlo al nivel molecular y
no solo a nivel macro podríamos ver qué
ocurre esto si tuviéramos un contenedor
voy a dibujar un contenedor aquí
del lado izquierdo digamos que al inicio
hay un grupo de moléculas que están
calientes
tienen una alta energía cinética tienen
una alta energía cinética promedio
y del lado derecho del contenedor hay
algunas moléculas son el mismo tipo de
molécula pero tienen baja energía
cinética promedio en promedio tienen una
energía cinética baja puede ser que haya
algunas con una alta energía cinética
pero en promedio tienen una energía
cinética baja así vemos que la
temperatura aquí es menor mientras que
el lado izquierdo tiene una temperatura
más alta
temperatura más
alta
ahora qué va a pasar estas moléculas
pueden interactuar unas con otras van a
rebotar entre sí las moléculas con alta
energía cinética van a chocar con las
moléculas con baja energía cinética y
todas estas moléculas se van a mezclar
pero incluso si de alguna manera no se
estuvieran mezclando estas moléculas
estarían chocando con estas y
transfiriendo su momento así que con el
paso del tiempo vamos a tener un sistema
que se ve algo así
donde todas las moléculas van a tener en
promedio una energía cinética mediana
todavía va a haber diferencias en sus
energías cinéticas pero no van a estar
divididos de esta manera entre la
izquierda y la derecha así que vas a ver
todo mezclado y vas a ver que ni las
moléculas de la izquierda ni las de la
derecha van a tener una temperatura más
alta
y así cuál es el efecto neto bueno
tuvimos una transferencia de energía de
las moléculas más calientes a las
moléculas más frías y esa energía de la
que estamos hablando es el calor
utilizamos la letra q para denotar el
calor
tenemos energía transferida de caliente
a frío es estadísticamente improbable
rayando en lo imposible pero hay una
posibilidad infinitamente pequeña de que
suceda que no va a poder ser observada
de que suceda en el otro sentido pero
eso no es lo que vemos cuando estamos
hablando de muchos muchos muchos ni
siquiera millones y millones de millones
de millones de millones de moléculas vas
a ver que los que tienen la energía
cinética más alta se mezclan y la
transfieren a los que tienen energía
cinética baja y es por eso que pudieron
decir no vemos ninguna transferencia
espontánea de calor de frío a caliente
siempre va a ir de caliente a frío